[MUSIC PLAYING]
JENNY BROWN: There are a
number of business benefits
that go along with moving
applications to the Cloud,
and certain workloads
are easier than others.
Apps running in the
Cloud require a variety
of storage solutions, including
block, file, or object storage,
and in some cases,
a combination.
Ultimately, you need to
find the appropriate storage
architecture for
each need because you
can't rewrite every app to
use one type of storage,
nor should you.
From a Cloud ops
viewpoint, where you store
is just as important
as what you store.
If you choose to use storage
options from multiple companies
or work with
third-party providers,
you'll be juggling multiple
UIs, setup requirements,
and access points--
not to mention, setting
up multiple IM, CMEK,
and other security
policies results
in context switching
that can seriously
impact your team's efficiency.
And let's be honest,
your folks would love
to have their weekends back.
Fortunately, Google Cloud
offers you a full portfolio
of block, file,
and object storage
to choose from, including NFS
storage solutions, so you don't
compromise on an SLA
or business value
that you're delivering
to your organization.
And if you're looking
for file storage,
we have multiple options
to best fit your needs.
For a quick overview of the
Filestore product family,
we have Filestore Basic, which
is built for many applications,
including test
and dev workloads.
Filestore High Scale is
excellent for larger storage
capacity requirements and
higher performance requirements
that many HPC applications
need, like genomic sequencing
or financial trading analytics.
Filestore Enterprise is
designed for critical business
applications, like SAP
and other use cases, that
also require high availability.
And having a simple, trusted,
and streamlined place to manage
these settings and get
things set up cannot be
underestimated.
Google Cloud gives you a simple,
yet powerful, user interface
to provision storage capacity
for applications utilizing NFS.
And if you're someone
that likes coding,
we have a single set
of Filestore APIs
you can use across the
entire Filestore family.
And for those who need to deploy
business-critical applications
in the Cloud, with many of
the traditional enterprise
features, like high availability
and integrated data protection,
we've built
Filestore Enterprise.
Imagine having
the protection you
need but with a Cloud-native
and fully-managed storage
service that has a
regional availability SLA
and file system snapshots.
Only in the Cloud can your
data be seamlessly replicated
to multiple zones
within a region,
all with a simplified,
single point of access.
And with Filestore
Snapshots, you
can rest assured that
any and all of your data
can be recovered within minutes
if the unthinkable happens.
For example, a Canadian
financial services company
moved its core SAP banking
systems to Google Cloud
as it digitally transformed
its operations in order
to improve its
client experiences.
However, they
couldn't compromise
with a nonresilient
storage solution.
High availability is of
the utmost importance
for their mission-critical
SAP systems.
And then there's a leading
travel reservation company
that underwent an IT
modernization initiative
and moved critical
applications to the Cloud.
They chose Filestore
Enterprise to store and protect
their information,
ensuring their Cloud ops
and their users could recover
any of that information
when needed.
No matter the demands of your
architecture or industry,
Google Cloud has a
comprehensive, trusted
portfolio of block, file, and
object storage to choose from.
And regardless of which
solution fits your needs,
you can keep things simple
with the unified Admin console.
To learn more about
Filestore Enterprise or any
of our Filestore
solutions, check out
cloud.google.com/filestore
and head to the console
to provision your own Filestore
Enterprise instance in just
a few clicks today.
[MUSIC PLAYING]